[Music]
well you're very busy with your new
podcast very exciting you're doing that
with Ben I gotta ask you now that he's
single what kind of woman does Ben need
and do you have anybody in mind I think
Ben needs a girl that's like low
maintenance you know he wants it like
into a natural church-going humble girl
who's like looking to go with him when
he does its mission trips and someone
who's a very good conversationalist for
sure just like sweets gets along with
everybody that's what he needs he just
needs like the ultimate girl yeltsin i
just checked back is he dating anybody
now or are you gonna set him up with
anyone I mean I think he'll be fun to
set him up in a little bit but right now
he's still in that you know
decompressing mode or he he just needs
to be alone for a while okay so he's
single yes he's very single what is our
single which is very single me very
single means that like uh he's like
mostly home and hanging out with his guy
friends okay he's having the guy
recovery time yeah how close have you
guys become and what have you learned
about him since doing this podcast
together what I've learned about Ben is
that he's even more perfect than you
think he is like is actually
unbelievable he's the best listener it
doesn't matter how frivolous what you're
talking about is he is fully invested in
what you're saying to him and it's just
it's so special and for somebody as
who's got it all and it's so beautiful
as he is he's just so easy to get along
with and talk to
I just don't my guts out to him every
time you guys are friends but could
there be anything more between you and
Ben Higgins I think right now we have a
good friend chemistry you know friend
mystery and there is one big thing that
you don't know about the answer what do
you think went wrong with him and Lauren
I think they just needed to live in
separate lives for a little bit longer
before committing like really really
taking marriage seriously
so you're saying the wedding is off
yeah man what about you miss are you
single what's going on I am single I'm
dating on hinge haha
you know like in people on hinge got to
go on some more dates do you think it's
easier for you though to date somebody
from bachelor nation because you've been
through those same experiences yes the
answer is it is easier to date somebody
from bachelor nation um I don't know if
it's like a good thing or a bad thing
anybody you have your eye on right now I
mean you know of course every girl
thinks Peter and Deena are pretty darn
cute so I'm gonna take those through my
favorites yeah sure if anything happened
[Music]